how are you doing sir
what's up brother i haven't seen you in
a little while all right how's things
it's good i'd heard you banned me from
doing junkets i'm glad i'm
i'm joking
today we'll see how today goes man
you're always on thin ice when they stay
i believe me i i understand um so i
gotta start with
for me it's pretty amazing that liam
neeson over the last decade
has just become this big action star and
people love
watching him kick ass what is it about
liam that people love watching him punch
people in the face
i think he's like i don't know there's
something kind of paternal about him
which we all trust
uh but uh i don't know he's just a bad
[ __ ] at the same time
and uh and i think it it works you know
he's a big old strapping handsome
lad and uh and uh he's got that um
he's got that amazing voice that great
vocal quality that we've all kind of
come to love and
i don't know he's just kind of one of
those stars that delivers on what
we want from him and uh i think he
pushes it enough to kind of keep things
really interesting but but doesn't stray
too far away from
kind of what we hope to expect and uh
and so fans stay loyal to that
you know and um yeah i mean look when
when this script popped up
you know it's the kind of thing that you
read and you go it's it can't it's what
you know couldn't be written for anyone
else
uh and uh i don't know i was thrilled to
kind of be invited to come along and
and and play the villain to his hero for
sure
i i have to wonder what it's like
actually filming you know
scenes with liam in between takes are
you like geeking out with him at all as
a fan
because he's been in so many like cool
projects
do you know what i mean i usually just
leave him alone uh in between takes
you know because uh it's um
it's uh i don't know yeah a little bit i
guess you're always like swapping
stories as actors on set
i mean funnily enough uh in honest thief
there's not
too much time that we're actually in the
same room uh even though uh i'm chasing
him for a portion of the movie and then
he's chasing me for a large portion of
the movie um
you know i actually got particular
enjoyment out of the fact that i got to
have
some phone call conversations with ian
uh
with liam through the thing because of
uh you know how much we've come to
to love his iconic uh phone calls you
know when that's happening that
the shit's gonna hit the fan and people
are gonna get hurt and
uh i was uh i was i was thrilled to be
uh on the end of a couple of those for
sure
is there something when you're making a
movie that you really enjoy
whether it be the action scenes or the
dialogue scenes or
is there like one part of the process
that really resonates with you
i mean not in particular i think it just
changes film to film
uh project to project you know sometimes
it's really
about uh mining through
the complexity of what your character's
dealing with
whether it's like a moral kind of issue
an ethical thing
um emotional stuff i mean like
you know depending on what it is i mean
shooting love scenes is really
challenging at times um
i've had to do intimate stuff like that
over the course of
of uh you know the short time i've been
working and and sometimes that presents
a lot of challenges sometimes it's
really tough action that just creates
um i don't know a lot of work for you to
do
physically and also the you know from a
choreographer's
choreography standpoint so um yeah for
this i mean it really like lent itself
to that i gotta say it was kind of
interesting to go back to some action
stuff i haven't done it for a minute
um and get busy with some choreography
there's some great tactical work that
that anthony and i got to do and try and
keep that stuff authentic and
and some cool fight scenes as well i
have a great fight with with kate
walsh's character with annie
which is kind of brutal um but it was a
lot of fun you know it always is and
when you put the work in and keep
everybody safe
um that sort of stuff can can be a lot
of fun to shoot
uh you were in a leader but you were
uncredited
uh what was that about
they wished i wasn't there no um
it was uh what that was about was i
auditioned for
another role in the film uh and
it didn't it didn't go my way um but i
built up a bit of a rapport with robert
rodriguez through that process
and we'd met prior to that as well and
um
he called me up they were already in
production and he said i got this part
uh it's it's pretty small roll but if
the thing kicks off
i'm gonna need to cast someone who i
know i can go back to
if we reprise it so um would you would
you do me a favor and come on down and
do it and so i was like
hell yeah yeah i thought that movie was
great and i really wish
it had made more money at the worldwide
box office
yeah i look i mean it's it's always
tough with one of those kind of things
it was visually amazing um and kind of
cool i don't know i
i guess i don't know it's hard to
predict what what
what audiences really have an appetite
for and um
you know the timing of certain things
it's i'd love to do another one i'd like
i hope that they can work that out and
and uh it was profitable enough for for
for them to kind of want to but um
we'll see obviously before i run out of
time with you i i have to ask you about
suicide squad because
i couldn't be more [ __ ] amped for
that movie yeah exactly uh
i know steve wait what what do you want
to know
i i know you can't say too much but i
what was your reaction
um like reading the script for the first
time what surprised you about james gunn
script
surprised me um i don't know i mean
there's
it's it's a big ass movie again as was
the first
um it's cool to see a bunch of new
characters
uh and and characters that he's plucked
from kind of
the depths of the cannon um which is
cool
uh and just kind of different and
interesting he he
i mean james likes creatures and
monsters and things as well so it was
kind of like
i don't know i felt like there was an
injection of that sort of stuff
um with this uh this take on it
um it's very funny uh and
i don't know man i mean it's it's it's
kind of what you come to expect from
this kind of film
um but uh i don't know people are gonna
have a great time with it it's
it's sad to see some of my my castmates
uh not involved but also uh i'm so
thrilled to
to welcome a whole bunch more in um and
i think it frees up
kind of the direction in which this
franchise can take you know it's kind of
like
crack things open in a way that i think
we now won't know what to expect
next time uh and i think that's cool for
something like suicide squad
um it's not necessarily even a strict
sequel uh i guess is is
is the truth and so i don't know it's uh
it's different man but it's
it people can have a ball with it and i
i hope it's you know massively
successful
i'm i'm very confident that it's going
to make what we call money
um yeah pretty confident um joel
kinnaman talked about how
he had to like hone his comedic skills
because he's not really like um
he's not really done comedy before but
in the first film captain boomerang you
know brought a lot of laughs
um is it similar in the sequel for me
yeah i mean i think it is i think it
would have been a shame to kind of run
away from
from that side of boomerang uh for sure
but uh i'm glad to hear joel saylor yeah
i think he
he got to have a little more fun with
with flag maybe this time around his um
he's uh he's you know his kind of
delivery on stuff shifts up a little bit
and it was it was fun to see him doing
that and
and certainly fresh for him and um i
don't know boomerang's the same
[ __ ] bag liability we came to learn
about in the first one and uh
you know he's he's out there causing
trouble as you would expect
saw those behind the scenes videos and
uh [ __ ] looks amazing
yeah it's going to be cool it's going to
be huge it's going to be a lot of fun
yeah um hey listen
congrats on this so happy to see you
again and uh
wish you nothing but the best why don't
cheers you too steve appreciate it